Timothy: You know, Drea,
I've been really looking forward
to all the machine learning
at Cloud Next this year.
Alexandrea:
That's a hot topic here.
Timothy: It is a hot topic.
So it's about time
that we checked it out.
We're here with Kaz.
Kaz, would you mind
introducing yourself
and telling everybody out there
what you do?
Kaz: Thank you so much.
I'm Kaz.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud.
Here we have so-called "Find
Your Candy" demonstrations
where you can tell
some voice command to the tablet
so that the robot can understand
your voice command
and try to find the best candy
for you
and pick it up
by recognizing the image.
Timothy: So there's a number
of different machine learning
algorithms going on there,
both in the voice recognition
and understanding
no just what you said,
but what it means,
as well as selecting the candy.
Can you just walk us through
that flow?
Kaz: Yeah, so initially,
it's using the voice--
Speech API to recognize
your voice,
and then it uses
the Natural Language API
to understand the words
inside the sentence
and then it uses
Cloud Machine Learning
to use the algorithm--
it's called word2vec.
word2vec is an algorithm
that's used to understand
the meaning of each word.
So it understands the similarity
between the hot and spicy
or creamy and milky.
And it tries to use the word
to choose the best candy
to pick up.
And finally,
it uses the Cloud ML again
to recognize the--
to the image recognition
on each object.
Timothy: That's a lot of machine
learning.
Alexandrea: Right.
Kaz: Yes. A lot, yeah.
Timothy: All right,
shall we try it?
Kaz: Yeah, you can try it.
Alexandrea: Let's see.
I like mints.
Little voice recognition.
Timothy: I see and it's finding
the whole sentence there.
It knows what each of those
words is.
I bet you it's gonna pick out
the noun, right?
Kaz: Yes.
So it understands all the--
the part of speech, right,
noun, adjective.
And now it's choosing
the best candy for you.
Timothy: Hey, look,
it chooses mints.
[laughter]
Alexandrea: So talk--'cause I know
we're sorting some candy here,
but talk to us, like, how this
translates for enterprises
and for businesses.
Kaz: Actually, this is
a miniature version
of the real world use cases,
and here we have
all the displays
for the cucumber sorter.
Actually, we have a real
cucumber farmer in Japan
who introduce--who used
the same technologies
to build his own
cucumber sorter.
And he spend only $15
to build his own cucumber sorter
by using Google Cloud machine
learning technology.
Timothy: That's really cool.
Kaz: Yeah.
Alexandrea: So, essentially, it
takes the best prototype of that
and kind of buckets them, or--
Kaz: Yeah, yeah.
So he wanted to
build a machine that can sort
out all the cucumbers
into nine different classes.
he took nine thousand different
photos of these cucumbers
and now and also built the
sorter by using Raspberry Pi
and downloaded TensorFlow,
the machine learning library
from Google,
to build his own sorter.
And the point here is that
you don't have to be
a cutting-edge scientist
or machine learning expert
to get started
with the latest machine learning
technology.